well thank you very much first of all i
want to thank the organizers for
providing me this form a very
very appropriate form particularly for
me
this year as you'll see and of course
i'm honored
to be asked to speak
what i'm going to speak about today is
very
uh connected with the program that's
running at the simons this
this semester and i should say that this
year i've been on sabbatical
in berkeley and uh as part of the miller
miller institute and as part of the the
simons institute and
both have been a wonderful delight to be
involved in this wonderful opportunity
for me
uh this semester and for those of you
who haven't gotten involved yet but
might be interested there's one more
workshop coming up on the 28th that
promises to be quite interesting
especially if you're interested in
stochastic processes and
probabilistic models this quite
a good group and there besides
these workshops there are lots of
interesting
seminars and reading groups and so forth
and most importantly lots of
interactions
uh interpersonal interactions at the
at the actual simons institute among
students and postdocs and
visiting faculty so this been very
successful from my standpoint
okay um well i i had a
little bit of a challenge for myself
this semester has been
allowed me to think about a lot of
different things and the program has
gotten me thinking even
more broadly and so when i got around to
thinking about what i would talk about
today i found
the challenge of a sort of more open
lecture
exciting and interesting although of
course i ended up very quickly not being
able to get everything in that i thought
should be
anyway this is what i intend to cover
today i hope i can
make it quickly enough uh
the first topic is not head-on other
than motivational
having to do with just making sure we're
all on the same page about what
has happened in the last say less than a
decade in
in sequencing and what the consequences
of that are
what at least one example that i'm
particularly familiar with
and then i want to launch into my thesis
about
this general topic of evolutionary
genomics what's
sort of unique about the history of the
field and particularly appropriate for
those
people who are interested in
quantitative analysis in
inference and strong tools in areas
where there are big problems
i think population genomics is one of
those and the history of it
throws a strong light on that i want to
point out just a few
of the interesting
problems or questions and and
contradictions that already exist and
are
becoming more and more serious for the
field and have to be addressed with the
new data
and finally i will spend a little bit of
time at the end
showing a couple examples of how to
address
might one might address these
contradictions uh with some
more recent full genomic population
genomic sequencing data
and also some interesting questions
about the scale of
of the of natural selection in other
words what magnitude of natural
selection is actually
important in some recent experiments
that i've been involved in
to detect really surprisingly
uh important but weak forces operating
okay so getting right along with it i'll
start off with a slide that
i wouldn't be surprised that most of you
have seen probably forgotten
but it's widely touted by uh
people in the genomics field especially
the nih nhgri this is this
uh plot of the cost of and for those of
you
in computer science you'll recognize the
sort of
poking that's involved here
the this is the costs per base pair or
per megabase of sequencing over
time and and during the human genome
project this
this line went down pretty much as
moore's law
both because many of the problems that
were being solved were
similar in some crude way with those
involved in the computer industry
but more importantly people discovered
very quickly that computers
were probably if not the most important
part of genomic sequencing they were
certainly the second most important part
of genomic sequencing
and so it was following the course of
the resources that they actually had
available
and then about seven years ago there was
a very rapid drop
after the after the human genome project
was finished
a number of new technologies came out
which are euphemistically known as
next generation technologies and the
price per base dropped very quickly
and you can see now it's leveled out
again probably
following moore's law more or less and
the
consequence of this technology shift
which i'll discuss a little bit in
detail in a minute
is broad and very far but most
importantly it enables
population genomics to actually take
place in a real
setting and it's happened most
profoundly in human
population genetics because that's where
the resources and the goal
goals were initially for the nih in the
welcome trust and many other
funders okay but i want to tell you
about the consequence of that
change in technology for genomic
sequencing in other words a human genome
was finished
but there are genomes that have not been
sequenced many
and some of them have not been sequenced
for very good reasons
and one of those is are the members of a
very
important not that big a clade but very
old
clade of conifers these are pine trees
and junipers and so forth gymnosperms in
general
these are very ancient plants seed
plants
and they have a very important role in
terrestrial ecology
but they no one has even dreamed of
trying to sequence these genomes
for very good reasons the genome size is
eight times human
no one thinks these days that the number
of genes in these kind of organisms will
be
eight times as big so that means the
increase in the genome size is largely
going to be repetitive
it turns out it is so that you have this
enormous amount of repetitive dna
even though the karyotype the actual
chromosomes of the organism looked at
through the microscope seem to be quite
conservative
it's chock full of repetitive sequences
we had an inkling and it turns out to be
a good hunch that
most of these repeats are
quite ancient or ancient enough that you
can distinguish them on a
at the scale that one that wants to do
next generation
sequencing and the cost of next
generation sequencing now is so low
that the actual cost of sequencing
such a huge genome to quite good depth
is nothing compared to the cost of
actually trying to assemble it and
understand it and it's just nowhere even
it's not even relevant
actually and much more important is
actually how you're going to do it
rather than the cost of sequencing
now the tools for assembling such a
genome are really not
we already know right out of the box
they're not going to work for two good
reasons one is
all of these repeats are going to be a
huge
problem for doing using
assembly techniques that depend on say
on well euphemistically people talk
about de bruyne graphs or
some very uh leveraged uh
string assembly basis that is uh
straight ahead those have big problems
with repeats and they have big problems
with errors
and the classic overlay overlap layout
consensus approach really doesn't scale
computationally
for this big of a genome because we're
talking about so much data that
actually to apply the sort of classic
algorithm that for example is used with
the human genome
would not be really possible so
one needs to come up with a better
approach and the approach is to do some
front-end reduction of the size of the
input data and
and to do that we we struggled to try to
think of what the most powerful ways to
do this
are but before i do that i just want to
remind a few of you who don't
remember or have never bothered and
maybe it's a good reason not to bother
because it may all go away eventually
what the sequencing approach is that's
used today
generally it's been proven quite strong
technique
which is just to take all the dna in the
genome shear it up into small pieces
and then this is a genome here we're
going to share it into these small
pieces
and then we have a technology that
allows us to read
the sequence from each end depending on
the size you might be able to read all
the way through but most of the time not
you have some sequence on the end of
these things and then you ask
a computer using one or another
algorithm to try to
find a a way to assemble these into
contigs sometimes they're gaps you hope
you can find another technology that
will bridge those gaps
and make those contexts into scaffolds
so we tried to use this technology but
as i said we had to do some front-end
data
reduction if you will i use the word
reduction and sort of
well i want to be more explicit the
first one is biological
unlike humans and unlike most animals
and actually most plants angiosperms
gymnosperms and especially conifers have
a very unique
biology that we can leverage very
strongly in this situation
i don't know when the last time you ate
it but when you very often if you're
eating
especially in the bay area you will run
into this thing right here on your
dinner plate this is a pine nut
okay so there's something very unusual
about a pine nut in biology
there are very few tissues in
multicellular organisms
plants or animals where you can get
actually a significant amount of tissue
that is haploid
in other words it only has the genome
from mom not from dad
and so the pie the nut part of a pine
nut which is most of the pine nut
can actually be isolated in the dna
extracted from that small
pine nut and there's enough dna using
sort of technologies that were
we used two or three years ago but now
we could even do more
to build a number of libraries from that
one genome
that are deep enough to actually
sequence very very deeply in that one
haploid genome
and the role of sequencing deeply you'll
appreciate in just a second
and that is we got a 75 billion
reads or cl molecules were sequenced on
both ends
and the first thing that we would do is
take uh
small we identify all the k-mers say 20
formers in the whole data set
and we would only allow molecules to go
through
where that particular sequence
with those k-mers in that sequence were
seen at least twice in the data so
anything was seen once was pitched out
so that's a very strong filtering for
errors
uh it works quite well got a huge
reduction in
in in in the data in in
reduction in error rate and and then we
after that we used what i would say it's
already published i didn't do this so my
colleagues
generated this algorithm which is a
fairly heuristic algorithm
for generating what they call super
reads which are basically you start off
with a paired in read
and then you try to extend the paradigm
read with another paired in
molecule and you end up with the largest
things that are
that are have at each end a paired in
read and the sequence in between is
completely filled in
and those are called super reads um
the actual algorithm is fairly heuristic
it probably could
use some regularization but it again
creates a very big reduction now
in in the amount of data going from uh
billions of things to a 150 million
super reads
these molecules or these constructs are
about
five to six seven hundred base pairs
long some are longer
but they are a size that will then and
then
a number that can go into classic
overlay
uh layout consensus algorithm this is
just the son of or the grandson of gene
myers
program that was used for the human
genome project we feed it into there
and didn't do the usual sort of messy
things that people do with genomics
assembly after you do the layout
assembly you go back and try to fill in
gaps sort of
post hoc with additional sequence and
then we did some more scaffolding using
rnas and so forth and that produced
on one hand a very good genome it's
almost the size
estimated from both cytology and from
simple k-mer counting
it looks like we have over 93 92 percent
of the genome
is is in contigs and
the the average size of the context
though is still small 8 000
the scaffolds are about 67 000 and so
there's still a lot to do
but the quality seems to be quite good
we compared it with some clones
that were sequenced from the genome and
assembled and we got very good
coverage of the clones that means
probably not a lot is missing
and we got very good identity of the
clones in the sense of
of a very similar sequence identity but
notice
that that the the the two megabase
scaffolds
that we have here um two million
scaffolds that we have
in this assembly are a long way from the
twelve scaffolds that are actually the
genome
which are the twelve chromosomes in any
case i
show you this to show you that there are
these
emerging problems where the the paradigm
for doing sequencing
is changed by having this enormous power
so that you generate so much data that
you actually have to come up with a sort
of
serious uh thoughtful process of
pre-processing it into
objects that can actually be assembled
by the known algorithms or approaches
okay now
that's just to sort of drive home the
idea about this technology
uh next generation sequencing changing
the
landscape of what can be done even for
de nova sequencing of genomes
but i want to shift now to population
genomics and
as i told you what i want to start off
with in my thesis
is this that population genetics or
popul the evolutionary genomics
for the first 70 or 80 years of its
existence
had very beautiful model
and theoretical basis and no data
now i can get away with saying no data
even with some of my best friends here
in the room
who generated a lot of data before we
were where we are today
because i tried to generate a lot of
that data too and looking back on it it
was a lot of work
but actually in the context of modern
genomics it was essentially no data it
was anecdotal
sufficiently anecdotal to keep us
excited but
actually in terms of the big problem it
will appear
minor as time goes on anyway
let me start off for those of you who
don't have been exposed to this to give
you
the sort of quick derivation of the
concepts that are
important in evolutionary genomics and
where they come from and
the basic question and problem uh really
was
the one that darwin posed and tried to
address which is
how does diversity arise and
spread and be maintained in in among
biological
individuals and populations and species
and
typical of his day and age he was
primed to move to a model
that basically leveraged the
difference in time scales and spatial
scales and he
seized on this idea that that really
it's the process the interaction that
happens among individuals in the
population
that gives rise to the diversity among
taxa
and this picture i just put in there
this this is from his actual notebook
this
is one of the earliest actual
phylogenies
that was drawn i i you might notice it
has some trichotomies and stuff so
his ideas about how speciation took
place are sort of interesting
probably wouldn't get you through your
qualifying exam today
anyway but the main problem that darwin
had
and he didn't make a big deal out of it
but it's assumed by many scholars to be
very
obviously painful problem for him and it
was for the whole field
was that the mechanism by which the
biological differences were inherited
was not understood by darwin at all
he he he created a whole chapter in one
of his books where he
he elaborated a theory that is no one
reads because they don't want to laugh
at darwin but but
it was quite clear to him and other
people for for a number of decades that
this was a
a serious problem that if you were going
to address the validity of
his ideas about evolution you would need
to have a better understanding of
inheritance
and completely on a different world in a
different scale
there was this fellow mendel who
was an avid scientific
mind and but a man of not great means
and so
using the his friends in the church to
get his an education which turned out to
be largely
in the physics department at vienna he
he uh
he got a pretty good education but then
he went back to
his high school teaching and so forth
and he pursued
his interest in plant inheritance
basically
in his own garden in that facility with
no support
and after a number of years he published
several papers one of his most important
one which was as i understand it only
cited a couple times in the first decade
or so so impact factor is very low
okay really h value or whatever it is
it's really not even worth mentioning so
he was completely
ignored but it's critical to understand
uh what he what was on there his mind
was open to the idea that maybe
inheritance
would be essentially discrete or
particulate
and that the material might be
transmitted in in
in units uh discrete units
and so he he really was able to embrace
this
and probably his trainings in
mathematics and
combinatorics might have played a role
in any case
after mendel was rediscovered people got
to work seriously on genetics
and especially the morgan lab in
columbia
started working on chromosome inherited
a chromosome basis of inheritance
and they they outlined linkage and its
relationship to
being the linear array of genes on the
chromosome
this is just a little figure here to for
those of you don't remember
genes can be if genes are on the same
chromosome they can be transmitted
in a parental way without recombination
in other words big a
and big b are transmitted just like it
was in the parent to the offspring
or if there's a crossover or
recombination then it can produce these
recombinant chromosomes which
these this group lady showed was a
physical exchange of material
and and so this is an important element
of the theory that underlies
modern genomic evolutionary genomics is
this
process of recombination the other
process that's important of course that
mendel
discovered luckily for him most of his
genes were unlinked and so
he discovered independent assortment of
genes that are on different chromosomes
so that they
it then this locus would segregate
independent of a and b
okay so the other thing that happened
that was important was the understanding
of where variation came from
and it was another it was a student of
morgan's mueller
who was the first person to actually
create mutations
uh sort of by force using x-rays
and he characterized their process
largely they appeared
they had a very random process even when
induced and
and and the ones he worked with were
mainly very severe lethal mutations but
largely behaved as points
as far as genetic experiments concerned
they were very discreet
and he the idea that there was a
mutation rate and it could be
in his case manipulated became part of
the
of the theory so these ideas formed and
they're very elementary simple ideas
they've laid the groundwork for
evolutionary genomics
and they're very simple ideas and the
only thing that needs to be added to
that is what happened how
organisms mate in most population
genomics
deals with organisms that made it random
because that gives very strong mixing
and independent assortment it makes the
equations much
simpler to interpret and i'll just
rush quickly through the sort of
founding uh contributions or
contributors to the field but actually
there have been
hundreds of brilliant people who've
contributed lots of wonderful things to
this field
meanwhile keep in mind there's no data
essentially
there's a little bit of data on
correlation among relatives but the
actual genetic material nobody knows
anything
and so fischer was the founder of of and
saw how to reconcile quantitative
genetic
character correlation among relatives of
those
with mendelian genetics and he
enunciated
a very important theoretical concept
that the
rate of of adaptation is proportional
to the variance the genetic variance in
that character
much work has been done in the last few
months at the
at the institute we've had many
discussions of this
this founding idea and elaborations that
have come out of that
quantitative genetics uh there were many
people worked on simple single locus
dynamics
uh one of the earlier contributors of
course was jbs haldane
and he's responsible for identifying
the simplest relationships between
mutation and selection
selection removing deleterious mutations
and and
and so and mutation putting them in the
sor
the person who really extension went
after and was interested and
enthusiastic about
randomness or stochastic processes
was uh sewell right to begin with but
many other people have followed
and and he characterized many of the
most important steps that
sarcastic variation or stochastic change
in gene frequencies
arise mainly by by binomial sampling
associated with what's called genetic
drift
but he also enunciated a lot of the
relationship between that and
and the equilibrium distribution of a
variation
under when those processes come to
equilibrium
as i said in the ins these guys were
sort of started out and a few other
people started
laying the groundwork with these very
simple ideas and then there's been like
60 or 70 years
of elaboration and investigation of
these things
and while some people have said that
it's been driven by
new observations of genetic variation i
looking back on it now i think it
actually thrived in the absence of data
it meant the theory could be elaborated
in any direction with any parameter
space that you might want to entertain
and because there was no data really to
to
narrow the scope of what we wanted to do
or consider okay so
that's a sort of background now i want
to just leap right up to
the present day and population genomics
and as i said most of the effort over
the last five or six years has been
in the human arena and they've had some
spectacularly interesting and
wonderful scientific advances based on
enormous amount of of dollars
in in iq point hours
and everything else poured into it and i
want to
just point out three that i think are
really uh
quite exciting and exemplary of what
we can probably expect to see more of
in the in the coming decade
um i should mention there the human
people have two main projects one was
called the hatmap project that was just
basically they went out and
collected a bunch of polymorphisms or
dna sequence variants
and they studied just those not the
whole genome and then
following that the thousand genomes
project was started where they actually
tried to sequence the complete genomes
of a thousand individuals and use that
data
to make inferences most of what i'm
going to show you now is based on the
hapmap data
although i'm sure more and wonderful
things will come from the
1000 genomes one of the things that
popped out of the earliest data
human population genomics data was
something that looked like this
there was anecdote there were anecdotal
stories in the human genetics literature
and other literature
about there might be recombination hot
spots in the human genome but they were
always sort of oh well it's an anecdote
maybe it's true
but it doesn't have any broad genomic
consequence but as soon as
people started to look at lots of
polymorphisms and they started measuring
the correlation between
a snip here and a snip somewhere else
nearby on the genome
and the redness reflects the statistical
significance of the correlation and the
frequency in other words
individuals who have say the a versus
the t
at this site are much more likely to
have the g versus the c
at this site within this block but not
with the site
over here because there's no there's
very little correlation between these
the snips in this part of the genome and
that so the scale here is
is megabases megabase or so
so what was obvious right away is that
there are these blocks
in the hypothesis and interpretation of
many people who
had worried about this for a long time
was almost surely these are hot spots
and immediately people went to the
toolbox
got out the population genetics
technology that had been developed
essentially without data
and applied it very quickly and swiftly
using
composite likelihood and other methods
to
estimate the the blue line here are
estimates of the recombination rate
along the genome this is
unfortunately not exactly the same
segment of the genome but the blue is
the estimates from this kind of a
data in other words from population
genetic variation
where you infer from the the
estimate of the history of the
population that there must be a hot spot
for recombination
at this point in the genome which would
correspond to one of these
junctions between the blocks the red
line here is just some co
very important validation data based on
actual genotyping of sperm
showing that in fact even in sperm you
can detect these hot spots
there is excess recombination at the
almost
many of the same places if not all okay
what was really to me quite spectacular
was this happened
about six or seven years ago and within
a matter of three or four years
the groups working on this got to the
gene
that's actually determining these hot
spots it's spectacular sort of
showing the force of genomic biology
to go from basically some pattern
in the genetics or some pattern in the
population genetics
to identifying this gene which binds to
a specific sequence
which happens to be more abundant in
these regions and that leads to a
modification of the chromatin
which then ultimately leads to a
crossover at that position
and and while the details of how that
part of the process goes on
it's pretty clear from work and mouse
and humans both pedigree and genomic
data
that that this is an important player in
determining these hot spots
okay now the other thing that i think i
would say
is that many people think not just i uh
that
the the really the most obvious and
biggest
impact of population genetics theory on
recent population genomics
was that all the theory about
how genetic variation in the absence of
selection
is distributed in time and space which
had been modeled ad nauseam and
you know maybe when you were a graduate
student and you had to read all these
papers
there was almost no data but there was
lots of beautiful equations and
wonderful ideas
and we couldn't really apply them to
much
and so when the when the human
population genomic data came
and now we're getting it from other
organisms there was all this machinery
that was ready to roll
and and what was remarkable what this
figure shows is even the simplest single
model you can even think of
to ask a question about demographic
history
has is enormously powerful in this
setting so this is a
beginning figure from a paper by lee and
durbin from
two years ago and basically they make
and they're making an hmm
to call segments with different times
to the most recent common ancestor based
on the frequencies of
heterozygous sites here in the genome of
one person i think it's craig vendor
so if you go along the genome there
you'll find some spots where there are a
lot of heterozygous sites and your
your hmm will then jump to say well
there's a
much more ancient common ancestor for
this segment of the genome
than that so presumably there had to be
at least one crossover because this
this part of the genome has a different
history than this part
and so this applying this technology
which is
basically sort of off-the-shelf stuff uh
you can get a very nice prediction
of the history which is the heat map
here and the red is actually
simulated uh data uh where that's known
what the history is
uh or um the time of the
time to the most recent common ancestor
and you can see that it's
quite sensitive even on a single genome
so this is something you can do with a
single genome
just take craig vendor's genome or your
genome go across the genome and you can
identify
places where it looks like the time to
the common ancestor
is much more much deeper or much more
recent
and you can average across the genome
and learn stuff about human
demography as a statistical population
thing very quickly so if you
average these things you can see that
the time to the
here's the recent expansion of humans
the effective
population size the time scale can be
converted under the assumption of no
selection into
time scale of population size
recent very exponential strong expansion
but before that there's a bottleneck
which largely corresponds
partially corresponds to the out of
africa but even the african populations
seem to have gone through a bottleneck
there's some controversy about
all that but in any case you can see the
expansion in africa
and then what the inferred historical
reduction in population size uh in the
african population
and then maybe it increased there's a
lot more
going on when one considers multiple
population multiple genomes
the real problem with multiple genomes
is that the computations are not
anywhere as straightforward
and much of the discussion or not much
but many interesting discussions this
last semester
have revolved around how to extend this
analysis that you do just on two genomes
and one individual
to a large sample to use up all the data
that we have
to make proper inferences about the
demography
of populations historical demography of
human populations
and i dare say you know in the area
we know a lot about the relatively a lot
about the historical demography of
human populations but very often in
other settings
ecological and management settings we
know almost nothing about the history
of population size and migration in
other organisms
and this technology doesn't distinguish
between any of those things can be
directly applied
to to any organism any population of
organisms
okay one last thing it's cute you
probably
may have heard about it yeah
oh the next one yes
this is a present years ago 500 000
years ago
i mean a hundred thousand years ago a
million years ago excuse me
uh years and this is population size
in for population size yeah okay
thank you what's going on on the far
right uh
that's a probably the thing is breaking
down most people don't like want to talk
about that
so tell me but that's that's that's an
area where
you know there's that's the part we
really want to know about
and so if people can think of much
better ways to get at that
you know the the theory is actually
they're using very little of
of the theoretical construct to do this
analysis
no i don't i i'm not sure i think people
don't really believe that
yeah yeah uh here's something cute
so long from the beginning of population
genetics there's been a whole way of
looking at things where you try to worry
about
whether the two genes that you got from
mom and dad or the two
one gene and your brother and one in you
are identical by descent in a pedigree
system that makes a that's a very well
posed problem
to you got genes that are identical by
descent either in the same individual or
different individuals
so what now in the genomic setting you
can ask what's
what's the distribution of segments of
the genome
that are identical by descent because of
recent common ancestry
because people move around and reproduce
and so if you
think of just this is just a cartoon
from the ralph and coop paper
and this is one individual who's
physically at this position in space
here's another one over here
this is a distribution of its ancestors
over the last 16 generations or the last
12 generations and
this is the green are the ones for this
individual and the black or gray ones
here
are the ones that are shared
between them and at all the size is the
proportion of the genome that's actually
uh
would be ancestral or the probability of
it actually it's a probability that
that that that any one part of the
genome is
is ancestral in that individual so
anyway it gives you some idea of the
time scale so we're talking sort of
five to 20 generations in sort of
realistic human parameterizations
and this shows you a pedigree where you
can identify the transmission of this
little segment of this genome and this
ancestor is transmitted down to here and
down to this individual
so those are ibb ibd and then you'll
notice here
this segment is also ibd from this
ancestor
so these these individuals actually have
two segments that are ibd
anyway these guys then went about
characterizing these patterns using
genomic polymorphism data from
populations throughout europe
and what you can see here the sizes of
these things reflect
the the the probability of of
of of one megabyte or one centimorgan
that's a measure of recombination uh
part of the genome being shared by two
individuals in that population
and then the rest of them are the
probability of the same thing a segment
of the genome being shared
between an individual and this
population and any of these other
populations and the color coding is just
some
identified population location
groups scandinavians you know
eastern european western europeans and
so forth
anything the thing you can see is that
by distance the
probability goes down and that uh
that the very close individuals are
there that
the other part of this is that you which
is sort of gets to entertainment
genomics is you can actually use the
same technology
to identify whether any two individuals
say in this room
uh share a common ancestor that was most
likely
in a village in poland you know 20 years
ago
because these things go to location when
you start adding a lot of individuals
that ibd segment has a place
and so it goes more to the entertainment
part of genomics but
still it's important anyway
okay so now i want to get on to real uh
sort of
more prospectively where the field's
going um let me see how i'm doing
okay 50 minutes
no it's okay all right so i want to
turn now to a couple things that i think
exemplify the sort of problems that we
have more generally in evolutionary
genomics from
from the standpoint of this new data not
from a purely theoretical standpoint
and and and talk you through a couple of
these examples
they exemplify two things that i think
are sort of the most
promising paths for evolutionary
genomics in the
in in the near future one is of course
to
elaborate mechanisms that have to be
incorporated into the sort of
canonical or accepted ideas about how to
think about evolutionary genomics
and what models need to be excluded
because
they can be excluded based on all this
data and the second
thing is a real when you don't have any
data as i said before
one of the most pernicious problems that
happens
is that you don't have to worry about
your parameter values very much
and so the scale of things like how big
does the mutation rate have to be or how
big does recombination have to be or how
strong does selection have to be
these things have never been taken very
seriously because there really never was
a lot of data
on which to reject or accept any
particular domain
for those and that's going to change and
is changing very rapidly and the primary
aspect of it is it's going to drive into
functional biology
the consideration of genetic
changes which cannot be detected in the
clinic or the laboratory directly
this now evolutionary genomicists have
always been willing to entertain those
kind of variation
but biology in general has not been
especially experimental biologists
have their paradigm for understanding a
biological system which is to break it
and fix it
if you break it and you don't observe
any phenomena then you can't tell
whether you fixed it
and so there's a there's a we're in the
midst of a sort of transition where
experimental biologists in the broader
biological community
is starting to accept the idea that
there may be parameters space
that's relevant that is not observable
in the laboratory
so let's take it back to the null model
the most common model that
is accepted and widely used as a
beginning for
understanding evolution genomic
evolution and population genomics which
of course
is the neutral model that most that the
variance
most of the variants are all the
variants or the ones you're looking at
have no functional consequence
and that some random processes probably
random sampling
drive their loss and fixation and a
classic
observation the first thing when it
became clear that molecular data would
when it started to become clearer to
linus pauling actually
was to realize that finally we're
starting to have
units one of the characteristics of this
period
that i was talking about the 70 years is
you have a science which had essentially
no units
no physical units they had this abstract
information unit which was an allele but
they didn't have any physical units
that related to the den actually to the
genetic information
that was being transmitted and with the
advent of molecular
techniques uh immediately the first
thing that came out was that
and this is something that appalling
sensed and was formalized by
other people especially moto chimera is
the idea that divergence would be equal
to the mutation rate and that's very
simple idea
you can have the expected number of new
mutations of course it's just
the 2n is the number of genes in the
population if we have diploids and
that's a mutation rate
and the probability that any one of them
will be fixed is is of course 1 over 2n
they're all equally likely
and so you see that the rate of
divergence is equal to the rate of
mutation and if the mutation rate
doesn't vary very much
then we have a a constant clock-like
phenomena
the sister of this equation which is
widely used in biology of course
is the one for heterozygosity
in other words random genetic drift
removes genetic variation every
generation by chance
and if mutations putting it back in you
get this very simple equilibrium
equation here
that predicts the amount of variation
that would be in the population the
average number of differences say
between two genomes and and one of the
earliest things when the earliest data
came in even before dna
uh dick lenten in uh raised this
contradiction in in its
part of this whole period of very weak
data that this contradiction was
basically
uh acknowledged and then ignored
for 45 years because we couldn't really
address it in any significant way
but when he raised it the person who
among others who immediately thought he
had a solution to the thing
was john maynard smith and maynard smith
said
well the answer is very simple uh what
you have is
that in populations occasionally rarely
mutations arrive with rare mutations of
course sincere mutations
arise and they're positively selected
and they very quickly go to fixation
in one over s where s is the selection
differential
for the for the mutant and as they go to
fixation
they drag along a section of the
chromosome because the recombination is
occurring but
on the scale of the selection
coefficient it sometimes happens and
sometimes doesn't and so around the
selected site
you get the fixation of a region of the
chromosome that was in this one
chromosome in that one individual that
got that mutation
so that leads to a little island
if you will of reduced diversity and
what mayor smith pointed out is in
larger populations you have more
mutations
and so you would have more fixations and
so more of the genome would look like
this
and so consequently the overall amount
of variation would never rise very high
because
bigger populations would keep
substituting more of those small
populations would have few and so
the total amount of variation might be
more similar between those two
yeah those stacks oh excuse me same
sequence
yeah so soon okay so let's let let me
just
sorry i should you very correctly raise
a good question
just imagine these are the a region of
the genome and these are
all of us okay and some of us have this
variant some of us don't
okay and then and let's suppose this
afternoon
uh one of us uh has
uh transmits a chromosome that has a
favorable mutant and then the process
goes on
and some one over s generations from now
everybody in the world
has that mutation and around it we have
a little island of fixation
okay
well this problem has not gone away even
though that
was 20 or 30 years ago and recently
these folks
wrote a paper review paper where they
looked at lots of different species
and the range of heterozygosities that
it's
predicted and some of these data are not
as good as others and some of the
outliers have biological issues that one
could raise with them
but in any case the overall impression
is still the same that it seems quite
narrow
and so we have this conundrum that if we
think that most of the polymorphism that
we see in natural populations is due to
due to
mutation and genetic drift just in and
out being lost
then why don't we see a bigger dynamic
range of the
variability because we know the census
numbers for
say drosophila versus humans is
is many many orders of magnitude
different
and that this is just a contradiction
which we we have one proposal from john
maynard smith there are a few other ones
that have been put forward that are um
uh
also use and leverage good population
genetics theory
they're they're not as uh well some
people
say they're better supported but i i i
chose not to present them all this
afternoon
okay let me put it that way okay so the
second thing i want to
oh i want to say well how could we ask
whether
hitchhiking which is the hitchhiking
effect was a john maynard smith
called that effect how what's a
prediction of that that we could test
well one of the things that became clear
when you do genomic analysis
is you could ask two things you can if
you have a recent hitchhiking event you
can see here
you have less polymorphism so you can
see here
since the common ancestor is very recent
and there's only been a few mutations
then there are very few polymorphic
sites in the region
and the divergence is more or less uh
the same or a little bit
maybe a little greater but anyway this
the characteristic of reduced variation
which is what we were just talking about
but the other thing that you can notice
when you have one of these recent
sweeps that wipes out all the variation
in some genomic region
is that the mutants that accumulate
after this hitchhiking event which i
represented by this bar are
turn out because of the nature of the
genealogy
that happens everybody has a recent
common ancestor right there
almost all the branches are all the the
branches are leaves
and therefore the mutations are all
singletons and so when you look at the
the frequency spectrum of polymorphisms
you discover that
hitchhiking produces a big skew towards
rare variants
and so we can ask about that too okay so
we have two things we expect
the polymorphism relative to divergence
to be reduced
and we expect the frequency spectrum to
be skewed
okay and i'm going to you'll see a
figure here it still has this term here
this is a sort of test statistic it's
actually the the log of the p-value
because the p-values are so large here i
took the log of the p-value
uh comparing the predicted
and observed levels of polymorphism and
divergence in windows of the genome
so now we are really jumping to complete
genomic sequencing of the whole genome
and this is one chromosome of drosophila
for a large sample of genomes
and the blue line is a windows of
polymorphism across the genome and you
can see it drips off here at the
telomere
here's the centromere over here and it
goes back down
here's divergence which is more or less
flat across the whole region
okay so it's not divergence is not
changing greatly across the chromosome
arm
but polymorphism is changing a lot both
on the small scale and on a large scale
and on the large scale we can notice
right away and we and it was noted even
before this data was presented there was
already good anecdotal hints
that that these regions have reduced
crossing over
so if you think about a hitchhiking
effect if recombination is less than the
region affected by the selected
locus will be greater and that's that's
a simple
explanation of that observation and
recombination rate also
reduces goes down more slowly in this
region of the genome which might explain
the incr the reduction in polymorphism
there now on a much finer scale you can
see these little regions here where
there's been
sort of wild reduction in polymorphism
relative to divergence
these are very small scale presumably
many of them although maybe not all of
them
are hitchhiking local recent hitchhiking
events where
a favorable mutant went through and
wiped out polymorphism
more problematic to interpret are what
are these ones that go in the positive
direction this means there's too much
polymorphism in that
those windows we don't have those have
not been analyzed and we don't have a
really good interpretation
although one could make some classic
models
to you i'm going to use classic models
to investigate those
in any case there's on two scales
there's sort of evidence for the
hitchhiking effect
and on the third observation which i'm
not showing you is that if you look in
windows and this across the genome you
will see that
that the frequency spectrum of
polymorphism is in fact skewed in this
region and down here
and indeed skewed under many of these
peaks that dropped down so
consistent again with the hitchhiking
effect having the recent hitchhiking
event in those windows
okay the last thing i want to talk about
which i might make if you
tolerated for a minute is this business
about
weak selection so most of the genome
if you think about it as a physical
entity is wrapped in is in chromatin
most of the things that contact the dna
are actually nucleosomes
so here are four proteins histone
proteins
they form an uh there are eight of them
together that form this structure here
and 147 base pairs of dna wraps around
that
this is the primary compaction of the
genome from meters
down to microns okay and that's achieved
by this
one interaction and 80 percent of the
genome is in contact with these four
highly conserved proteins the most
significant dna protein interaction for
the genome by far
energetically space footprint everything
else is this one right here
okay yeah what functions are
as far as anyone knows they package dna
now that said you see these little tails
sticking out here
there are whole departments recent
departments formed around
maybe not around one tail but maybe
three of those tails
okay so epigenetics takes place on these
tails largely although some of the
things in the backbone are also modified
but they they play a role in
when the when the genome actually
functions these things have to get out
of the way
and then and they also mark parts of the
genome there's lots of information on
those molecules
that's not coded in the protein but is
added afterwards
okay but the fundamental compaction of
the genome involves these
very conservative parts of the genome
and those these
147 base pair particles are then
packaged into
higher order structures to achieve
ultimately the kind of
very strong compaction of the genome
that's important
the important thing to remember is
whatever happens in the genome whether
you replicate it or you express it or
you do anything else
you've got to get those nucleosomes out
of the way or you at least have to put
them on the side someplace and keep them
in a special place
you have to do something to get through
because you have to unwind the dna
the double strands of the dna you're
going to have to displace it
when you isolate these things from the
genome
and you look at the dna sequence that's
actually in there there's nothing
particularly remarkable about it
except what jumps out right away and it
was with the first 183 sequences that
were observed more than
25 or 30 years ago was the dinucleotide
periodicity
so and it's a 10 base paired periodicity
so
the dna if you remember turns every 10.4
base pair so every 10.4 base pairs
the frequency of a particular
dinucleotide say aa goes up and down
okay and so those aas interact with a
protein
in specific place and there are other
dinucleotides that are also 10 base pair
periodicities
that interact in other places so this is
just to say what i just said
there's these dinucleotides are
understood
from physical chemistry to affect
the wrapping of the dna around they make
the dna backbone curve
around the protein and fit on the
protein they lower extra stratic
interactions with particular uh
amino acids that interact the gc
dinucleotide is has the opposite effect
it's on the ends
when it's on the inside it's in the
major groove so
if you remember the dna helix is not
some completely symmetrical there's a
minor groove in major groove
and it's on the inside when it's on the
inside it interacts
and so the question is what forces
shape these patterns is it mutation bias
or is it uh is it
actual function in other words are these
interactions required to really make a
functional good nucleosome
well it's been a roaring controversy for
a number of years
decade or more because one thing is
there wasn't
actually exquisite data on down to the
base pair so people who were modeling
and they had machine learning models
trying to figure out where nucleosomes
were
but they didn't actually have the
nucleosome sequences in great abundance
and so there was a controversy about
which of these processes is important
and so what we did in uh
to to address this and this leverages
the genome sequencing technologies that
i'm telling you about
is we isolated nucleosomes got out the
dna from the nucleosomes sequence those
nucleosomes
and and in the past people have been too
stingy to throw out all the data
except the 147 but if you throw out all
the data except the 147 of course you
achieve one base pair resolution
and immediately you see here is the
dinucleotide pattern that you see in the
dna in the dna
and what you see is the divergence
follows
the implied pattern in other words
if you were ancestrally a g in a region
where
a is preferred you're much more likely
to diverge to an a
and if you were ancestrally a g an a in
a region where g
is preferred you're much more likely to
diverge to a g
now if you're thinking about this very
much you can say still could be mutation
the nucleosome should be guiding
mutation so that it just
fits this periodicity why not it's
intimate interaction
well this is where population genetics
comes in one last time
it's just an example of what one can do
with the sort of theoretical constructs
that exist
but for example it's a very simple
thought process if you if mutation is
biased
that's fine but once an allele arises
it's just any other allele
and its frequency should be the same
whether it arose by a positive bias or a
negative bias
its frequency in the population
if and the only thing that could change
that frequency is if it had a functional
difference that
affected fitness so
what one can ask is not only what about
divergence but we can ask
what is the frequency what are the
frequencies of alleles
that have arisen the preferred alleles
and unpreferred alleles
okay all right here a little bit busier
but for example if you look over here
here are the gc
dinucleotide frequencies in blue and
here is the
a measure of the of the deviation in the
frequency spectrum
uh for g uh gc polymorphisms
and you can see they line up perfectly
so it's very clear that the preferred
allele
is more common in those positions in the
nuclear zone where the
it tends to be a g or c in that position
and the and the unfavored allele is less
common
so this is very strongly consistent with
the prediction of
natural selection the thing i should say
is the molecular biologists as far as i
know have never found a mutation
whose function is mediated through the
binding of a nucleosome
especially through the bind to the
dinucleotide interaction
so these it could very well be and i
think when faced with this many
molecular biologists were would be
willing to accept not do accept
the idea that maybe nucleosomal
functions are important
but they're inherently sort of one
percent or tenth of a percent actually
biologists can rarely
measure 10 1 in the laboratory so
if we imagine that these things are
inherently weak they're still
quite strongly selected the last thing i
would say about them is if you remember
i said 80 percent of the genome is
wrapped
in this stuff so the actual selective
footprint of this
is comparable it's on the order of the
same magnitude as coding regions
because of the huge footprint in the
genome
i'll just leave this up here this is
more or less what i covered today
i don't have time to really go into it i
think
okay so you've given us a marvelous
story about how the
techniques have to improve and see more
and more of the details
and you speculate just a little bit of
what might be
you know the the first payouts now or
human time
what
oh man i see i see i it's hard for me to
choose
you know if you get it like just one
drink in me i start to talk about
entertainment genomics is the most
important part
to be honest uh but i mentioned
i i maybe it's my intellectual
environment that i work in but
the people who are going to be most
greatly impacted by genomics besides
doctors and maybe school teachers i
don't know how i feel about that
certainly law enforcement i hope less
but anyway the people who really are
going to be impacted scientifically
are going to be people who study
populations of organisms in nature
because the tools that ecologists
and demographers have to figure out
what's happened and what's going on in
populations
very crude tools they have to like catch
and toe clip the lizard and then catch
it again
you know it's really hard work and you
don't get much information
this gives you information on many
orders many time scales
very quickly you just grind up a bunch
of these individuals and sequence them
so i think for people interested in
population biology broadly
and it might even extend to you know
human sociology
there's great potential there i i
as a matter of professional approach i
never
almost never comment on health related
things because
it's in good hands as they say you know
anyway so i guess that's where i see one
i i also wonder about
you know and you you guys who might have
better ideas about this i i wonder
whether
as one pushes these things along and
tries to get more out of the data
what the sort of the sort of
tool development or conceptual
development
will be on the impact because
historically
trying to understand population genetic
variation has had a huge impact on
statistics
in other areas and now we're going to
enter another era
and so it could be that there'd be quite
a
an effect there although i have to say i
don't see it
yet
michael so this idea of wheat selection
on
nucleotides associated with binding is
fine but
a lot of those nucleotides are also
doing other things right yeah so
yeah those everything i showed you was
non-coding
but let me just say you can sort of see
it even in coding regions a little bit
but but anyway this is all non-coding or
intron it's either intron they're
introgenic
so the suspected function is too large
what the function you suspect of this
periodicity
is to help lodge actually if you ask
it's it's amazing these are very the
people who work on nucleosomes
they have a first of all they solve the
beautiful structure it's one of the best
structures in biology
and they're really smart hard-working
people
but the actual physical chemistry of
nucleosomes is
pretty mysterious the forces are weak
and and they say well of course they
have to be weak because you know it has
to come off and on all the time
in it but it has to be the dna always
has to be wrapped in these things
but it has to come off and go on and so
it's thought that it has to do with the
kinetics of the actual nucleosome coming
on and off assembling and unassembling
that may be the important functional
part
kinetics yeah you know
who knows i mean i i there are people
you know are trying
people try to study these things in in
one can hope that maybe some of these
results will interact with sort of
physical thinking about what nucleus
homes do
well there's a very well solved crystal
structure for a single nucleosome well
for
probably six nucleosomes different
nucleosome
things um they're very they're very high
quality but of course they're not
solid and it's well known that the if
you look at
nucleosomes in in solution they breathe
they come on and off a little bit and
everything
but they stay put i mean
you know they're they can slide they can
be
moved by remodelers proteins with
energy that can move them around they do
get moved around but they do stay put
and they wrap the dna
i'm not a microbiologist so you know you
can tell i don't
really know what i'm talking about
okay